I was going to say for you was there
ever any um opportunities that came up
that you passed on or that you didn't
decide to go with when it comes to like
maybe taking a direction or stpp in the
direction of being more on a major
situation or a bigger distribution
situation yeah damn near um you know I
didn't sat I didn't sat with labels bro
I didn't sat with uh I sat with Rock
Nation you know I mean I sat down with
rap a
lot to lot yeah for sure shout out to
Trey you know I mean shout out to Jay
Prince I sat down we had a conversation
we talked about the vision you feel me
and he asked me like what I wanted to do
he was ready to do everything that I
wanted to do you feel me but like
whoever kind of was like middleman in
the situation I don't think he knew like
that they was you know talking the way
that they was talking cuz I had a
conversation with J Prince so that
wasn't the conversation we had when I
talked to the you know the middleman and
all that you feel me so it was just
something different you feel me so I
just chose to stay independent you know
what I mean until I can holler at the
boss man you feel me myself on the boss
man tip yeah no I mean that I think
that's cuz what you are you doing Toon
Core drro kid how you putting out your
[__] right now man I'm strictly
independent man it's 258 no breaks man
no but you got to obviously you got to
get the music out of course so like what
service do you use I don't use no
service I am the service man so you
don't have I'm putting my [__] out man
so you're putting your [__] directly on
the dsps yeah oh okay that's great N I
ain't doing it myself but you know I
don't want to give away well cuz like a
lot cuz like you know for people who
don't know there's like Dr kid and toon
Corp which in my opinion make it very
easy to be independent n for sure let me
not pay producers shout out to to cor
though shout out to to core I've been
rocking with them since day one CU all
you're still fully independent all
you're doing is paying them a one time
fee and giving and giving everybody what
they entitled to you can do splits right
exactly you can do that now yeah cuz
that's the one thing is like when you're
an independent artist I'm sure it can
get really really like yeah overwhelming
to make sure the producer gets taken
care producers got to get taken care of
theit compos anybody that had anything
to do let me break you off here's your
points yeah for sure yeah but you know
but that's what the majors don't do you
know what I yeah they rather they rather
they rather buy your percentages out
they rather give you a nice well and
they'd rather like dick you around as if
you're a writer or a producer there's a
reason you can get the same you can get
the percentages but not the money and it
takes forever yeah you know I just saw
internet money uh the dude who runs
internet money was saying like I'm going
to start calling some of these major
labels out cuz you guys over a year
passed do on some of my producers like
fees like it's like these yeah after a
while you look around and you be like
man the numbers don't add up some ain't
adding up the numbers ain't adding up
you feel me but like when you when you
don't see that dashbo War when you
really don't see the actual numbers and
where they going you know they say
numbers don't lie that's a lie numbers
lie too for you do you notice like um
cuz I always try to look you know I
talked to Paro about this a little bit
but he's like look now that I'm
independent and I'm off Rock Nation he's
been leveling up because he could drop
whenever he wants and he was like now
when I drop it's almost like the stock
market like I put some new [__] out and
everything else spikes up like the rest
of my catalog gos up yeah so that's the
beauty of it just keep on being
consistent you can't just drop a project
and then wait two three years and drop
another project like that's why I really
didn't want to tell nobody cuz you know
[__] be you know watching how I
do my little [__] yeah you feel me but I
ain't going to lie as soon as a ball
drop I drop January 1st I'm dropping a
project February 14th I'm dropping
another project March whenever I'm
dropping another project like right
you've been on it bro I'm dropping 12
albums next year bro so next year year
Dr 12 albums one each month how much
music right now are you sitting
on uh unlimited bro I can't even really
imagine how much music I got cuz I still
got old stuff from me and nip we did
back in the day in 2006 and crazy Beyond
you feel me what do you do like do you
like what do you do with that with those
records uh do we just do you just keep
them is there a time and a place to Dr
always had conversations about just you
know running the music up first running
up what we got now MH and you know just
built that catalog and then like
introduce them to the old [__] but that
was when I didn't have a crazy catalog
you feel me so right yeah I got a crazy
catalog now so we can kind of like bring
up them old uh Myspace mixtapes and
crazy yeah you know what I mean a lot of
that unreleased [__] so yeah